بعد ظهر يوم مزدحم في grindhouse killer
burgers في أتلانتا في القائمة ، ما هو
البرغر الآخر في الولايات المتحدة
الذي تم الاحتفال به على حد سواء باعتباره
مفضلًا أمريكيًا ولكن تم تشويه سمعته أيضًا فهو
غير صحي ومع ذلك يظل برجر اللحم البقري
ملكًا للأمريكيين يأكلون ما يقرب من 60 رطلاً من
اللحم البقري سنويًا.  أكوام ما يصل إلى
بضع مئات من الهامبرغر ، من
المتوقع أن يؤدي ظهور جيل جديد من اللحوم إلى
تغيير ليس فقط صناعة لحوم البقر نفسها
ولكن أيضًا نظام إنتاج الغذاء العالمي بأكمله
عندما تم طرح ما وراء اللحوم
للجمهور في وقت سابق في مايو من عام 2019 ، فقد شكل ذلك
نقطة تحول رئيسية أخرى في
ثقافة الغذاء والصحة في الولايات المتحدة ،
تبع ذلك أكثر من عقد من
البحث والتطوير في البرغر
المصنوع من النباتات وليس فقط من خلال ما وراء
اللحوم ، كان الهدف منتجًا يمكن أن
يكون له طعم البروتين
ومذاق اللحم الحيواني.
حل مشكلة البروتين هذه إذا كان
لدينا كوكب مستدام إذا كان
لدينا سكان أصحاء ،
اللحم البقري المتنامي مع اللحم البقري  خاصة
زراعة المصانع يرجع ذلك جزئيًا إلى أن الأبحاث تظهر
أنه ضار بشدة
بالبيئة
وفقًا للأمم المتحدة ، فإن لحوم البقر وحدها
مسؤولة عن 41 في المائة من
انبعاثات غازات الدفيئة للماشية مثل
الميثان وأكسيد النيتروز ، وتشكل انبعاثات الماشية
14 ونصف في المائة
من إجمالي الانبعاثات العالمية
[موسيقى
] صباح جميل في مراعي البلوط الأبيض
، مزرعة عضوية في بلافتون
بجورجيا ، هل قامت عائلة هاريس بزراعة
هذه الأرض لأكثر من 150 عامًا ، وهو
يميز بشكل واضح بين الطريقة التي
يدير بها عمليته ونوع
إنتاج اللحوم بكميات كبيرة الذي تم العثور عليه
ألحق الضرر بالبيئة ، أنا واحد
من الأولاد القلائل الجيدين الذين اعتادوا الزراعة
صناعياً
واتبعوا ممارسات إنتاج إنسانية متجددة ، لكننا نقول
إنها ليست البقرة بل المنزل ، وأوافق على
أن إنتاج لحوم الأبقار الصناعية يضع
كميات هائلة من ثلاثة غازات لطيفة.
تحطيم الحياة الجرثومية النموذج العضوي
ما خلقنا في التربة
نذبح 35 رأسًا من الماشية في دات
مصنع صناعي كبير في المجزر
400 رأس في الساعة ،
صناعات مختلفة ، اللحم هو اللحم الموجود على
جزيرة أعتقد أنه من
المثير للاهتمام حقًا أنه في عام 2019 يتعين علينا أن
نقرر ما هو أنا